yeah hey well though birdie was telling
me Dee wasn't too fond of how we were
talking about a few episodes ago look at
me the song told me that Dee was coming
with the heat yeah you racist best as
well well I mean you mean racist bastard
if I'm racist dude I would know I'll let
you know as well okay my my brain trauma
made me racist it's kind of an excuse oh
yeah I liked everyone before I started
you knocked out oh yeah yeah I could see
that man I could see you uh yeah but
then you changed him in a big brown to
be all-inclusive yeah because then I can
throw around whatever words I want yeah
people like he's not bike I'm like but
he's big brown you know he's mauve gives
me the right you know
yeah he's plum oh I could imagine that
dude I could imagine you Chin's running
the keyboards today shout-out to a Nick
and Derek ya know and that is very
passive-aggressive in jail right now for
we don't know but involves small
children boy then Derek is on the road
with Pauly Shore so you can't be um
mushy Oh what Yoshii Yoshii
Mount Korea angry that's what I think
I'm not angry change mad when he has to
run the run the ship no not again
Rick's here no Nick's here but Derek's
gone he's on vacation
also Derek you missed four shows in a
row bro yeah anywhere else you're fired
about how black you tryin to get there
huh
how black you're trying to get there bro
anywhere else you for fire but here's
the thing he used they're always the
most predominant black excuse used
family reunion [ __ ] I was like okay four
weeks in a row and I had to say the only
families that have family uses that long
are black people and Indian people
that's correct if used to do it an
Indian family reunion two years it'll be
at your local park you go there and
you're like what still there everyone's
older you're growing crops and stuff
you're like what is rust affari no
that's
back what up Barbara how are you man
welcome back where were you oh man it
was Pauly Shore in [ __ ] Florida man
it was awesome Wow for a trial no he's
still doing comedy man - no I'm actually
him he might be I don't know what that's
probably Pauly's a legend
no he's the greatest but he still might
be doing a scene oh man - what do you
really know I hoped it I would love that
bro what if he came back and didn't see
no man - I wasn't trying to make a joke
though yeah I wish they did movies that
were mashups like Encino man meets mrs.
Doubtfire and they fall in love or
Encino man turns into mrs. Doubtfire no
yeah like he's babysitting the kids and
then she kicks him out and he comes back
as a woman Oh like that actually it's a
pretty good idea actually how you got it
is the question did you have fun Dee oh
my god so much fun dude yeah you got you
legs for like a month huh you always
take off huh apparently just take off
was with my family for a week bar black
people's barbecues don't last five weeks
as you said oh you heard that black
people barbecue is not automatically a
family reunion it has a very very
similar to Indian culture on notice
you'll see like a Indian barbecues at
the park
- three months bro you see though like
some of those barbecues but sometimes
black family reunion it just keeps going
you know yeah we know we didn't have all
matching shirts on did you really yeah
of course hell yeah crazy
shirts yeah we're posting team like
names on the back damn right you did and
so what do you guys do was it was it
really like a big family event
yeah we just universal studios all the
theme rides and parks and [ __ ] was [ __ ]
I just go as a big group me all dressed
the same yeah one of Brandon's favorite
things to do sounds cool
do you guys stay that night oh yeah oh
yeah my dad made us watch the water show
every [ __ ] night
Wow Jesus Christ dude we figure an Asian
broker that sounds like a very Asian
thing watching a water show every night
yeah it was pretty asian hey I didn't
see any pictures though you didn't post
any pictures I didn't know my family was
posting every second so I was like I was
gonna try to enjoy this the gram had to
thanks
well welcome back man we had angry chin
in here and cats back to from her car
accident yeah did we upset about that
man
no I'm not upset about [ __ ] little
big brown over here looking like Drake
if he was a hot dog eating champion
looks like [ __ ] what a George Bush is
wise whatever don't think their sign-off
you could say you like Drake if you like
what a Bill Clinton's [ __ ] mistress
to little Debbie's mistresses dude
you're like Jackie Kennedy can't even
think I have a headache we deserve that
yeah we deserve it let's kick this off
you guys ready to get going
back up my broccolini get your life
together I'm not